Rory, old pal, how are you?
I am so good.
I am doing so great.
I'm--
Really?
I'm not mentally affected
or physically affected
by the current state of the world.
I am terrific.
I've been doing a lot of Zoom interviews,
with a lot of people.
Your setting looks the shittiest.
I'm gonna say that right now.
And that's what I was going for.
(Conan laughs)
There's a lot people out there...
Look, here's who you've had
as guests, Conan, liars.
They wanna decorate back here.
They wanna go, "Things are great!"
It's like Instagram,
what people are doing on Instagram.
Not me, not me.
I didn't even put that there,
for anyone who can read it.
Well, you can barely read it.
I love that even your sign,
promoting your new show "Robbie"
(Rory laughs)
on Comedy Central
is impossible to read.
I didn't put that there.
I would never take credit for that.
All right, well, listen,
we've got a lot to talk
about, you rascal you.
I was thinking about your life.
You're a road comic.
You're constantly on the go.
You're always away from your daughter.
It must be so nice for you
to be spending time with her.
It is.
My wife probably wishes I
could get back out on the road
right about now.
But yeah, with my daughter,
we're playing games nonstop.
And yeah, we're...
When you're gone,
You go on the road, you come back.
That's what the relationship is.
To actually be home, is a
whole new type of relationship,
and it's great.
It's the best.
Good.
Oh, there she is.
Hi, hi, Elliot!
Do you see Conan?
Say, "Hi, Conan."
Hi!
Hi.
You look pretty, Elliott.
Thanks.
This is mine.
Who told you, you could borrow that?
(Conan laughs)
[Conan O'Brien] She stole--
It's mine!
No.
stole that from you.
That's terrible.
Please, daddy.
What?
Do you wanna play hide-and-go-seek?
Hide-and-go-seek?
I am talking to Conan.
But why don't you hide,
and then I will come and get you?
Are you really gonna try to find me?
Or are you just gonna tickle
me into a tickle fest?
Well, I'll do both.
If I find you, you are getting tickled.
Okay.
Yeah.
Bye.
You better get out of here.
Get!
Ya get!
(Conan laughs)
So she's gonna go and hide?
Oh, I didn't want America to see
that I talk to her like that.
Is she going to...
She's gonna hide now,
and then you're gonna go look?
Here's the thing,
hide-and-go-seek is one of the best games.
These kids, they don't know
how long it takes to be found.
And if they commit to the hiding place,
it's a good hour, two hours,
of just catching up on some golf.
You know what I mean?
Well, I don't think that's a...
So, wait, you just are gonna let her
hide somewhere in the house
for up to two, three hours, while you--
Yeah, and her adrenaline
is pumping the whole time.
My adrenaline's pumping,
because I'm getting some stuff done.
I'm watching TV, and...
You know?
Okay, yeah.
That sounds--
One time, she came out.
She was hiding, and she came out.
And I was having ice cream,
and that was very traumatizing for her.
For her.
Not for you.
No.
For her.
The best for me.
All right, well, I...
You should go and...
Why are you drinking out of a jar?
Vodka in a jar.
Starting a new company.
It's called Vodka In A Jar.
Nothing says "issues" like
vodka in a jar. (laughs)
(Conan laughs)
I think you're gonna make a lot of money.